Hi, I'm Erik Voss, and we have a third, new
trailer for Spider-man Homecoming. And
because we apparently can't get enough
of these, we also have a separate new
international trailer that also came out.
And between both of these trailers,
there's actually a lot of new footage
with a ton of interesting details. So I'm
going to go through and break down all
the new stuff in this great domestic
trailer, adding new interesting bits from
the international ones throughout. So, let's get started.
"Finally. Here we go. Good
evening, Peter. Whoa! You have five hundred
and seventy six possible web shooter combinations. That is awesome!
I can keep that suit? Yeah, doesn't fit me.
When's our next retreat? Look, next mission, we'll
call you. Alright, it's not a hug, I'm just grabbing the door for you.
There, yep. All right kid, good luck out
there." Ok, so right away this trailer
shows off a new feature of Peter's stark
designed Spidey suit: an inner CPU with
an AI voice and an augmented reality
interface, similar to the inside of iron
man's helmet. Now yeah, at first it seemed
like this tech is a little too advanced
for a spider-man suit, which
traditionally is supposed to have a more
practical DIY kind of design. Like,
spider-man isn't Iron Man for a reason.
Being low-budget is part of his charm.
But I think this is all part of Peter's
character arc in this movie. Like, we know
from the last trailer that Stark
confiscates his suit later on. And check
out the way Peter says 'finally' here. It's
almost like he's been waiting all day to
play with his suit, like it's a video
game that he can finally play after
finishing his homework. So - to Peter, this
suit is like overwatch, and then like
many teenage gamers, Peter uses it to
start sh*t with adults and then, father
figure Tony Stark steps in and grounds
him, takes overwatch away from him, and
then, when Peter learns with great power
comes great whatever, he becomes a man
finally and invents his own damn
overwatch. See? The classic coming-of-age
tale. This opening section also shows us
more of Peter and Stark in the backseat,
and I feel like we've seen so many
pieces of the scene in each trailer, and
that could mean that they actually shot
a lot of alternate dialogue and jokes
for the scene. Like, you may have noticed
in recent years that trailers have
included slightly different dialogue
than the versions of these scenes in the
final theatrical release. Nowadays
directors will shoot some takes solely
for the marketing people who assemble
the trailers. Like, remember that shot of
Jyn Erso in the first rogue one teaser
which Gareth Edwards apparently got
just just by yelling Felicity Jones' name
on set and recording her reaction. Yo
Felicity, we gotta make a trailer! Anyway,
I know I obsess over the exact footage
that are in these trailers, but I'm just
keeping my fingers crossed that this
movie will feel new and surprising when
we see it in theatres. Cool, let's move on.
"Hey, Peter! You coming tonight? I can't tonight.
I got the Stark internship. What's up,
guys? Mr. Stark, here's my report for tonight: I
stopped a grand theft bicycle. Hey,
could you do me a favor? Hold on to that. Is this anybody's bike?
Oh, I helped this old lady and she bought me a churro, so... that was nice." Okay, here we see some
more shots of Peter as a typical high
school nerd that we saw in past trailers,
but also a few new examples of him as a
local, friendly neighborhood spider-man,
catching a bike thief and bragging that
an old lady bought him a churro. And what I
like most about this is how not a big
deal spider-man is. Like, notice how he's
not an Avenger-level celebrity that
people are trying to take selfies with.
In fact, when we hear a camera snap as he
poses by the subway platform, I don't see
anyone on that platform taking the photo.
Like, this is probably just one of his
own cameras that he rigged up ahead of
time to take pictures of himself. So this
is just such a fun, grounded total
choice for the movie. Like, even as a
superhero with a really cool suit he's
still a loser. Hey, look at me! Let me save
you! Meanwhile, all these jaded New
Yorkers are just like oh wow this little
loser thinks he's old metal face and a
green fatty? Get outta here! Like,
even Tony Stark won't take his calls. He
just leaves these voicemails documenting
the friendly neighborhoods bullsh*t that
he did that day that Stark probably
never even listens to. Now, the
International trailer actually opens
with Peter keeping these geeky records
in a totally different way: vlogging.
Shooting behind the scenes footage of
the airport battle and Civil War, it also
shows him gushing about it in the hotel
room afterward as Happy interrupts him.
And notice here that the web shooters that
Peter is wearing on his wrist look
different from the web shooters that we
saw him wearing under his clothes in
Captain America Civil War. These, of
course, are the new Tony Stark upgraded
one with 576 different web shooter
combinations.
He's probably going to wear these all
the time. Just, uh, Peter be a little
careful that you don't wear them out. Now,
the question I have about all this is if
Peter wants to keep his identity secret,
why is he vlogging about this stuff
with his mask off? So I guess this could
be like a private video journal that he
keeps for himself, but I have a theory
that he could be making these videos to
confide all these amazing experiences
with someone, maybe his deceased Uncle
Ben. Like, this is how he keeps his
memory alive. Or maybe Peter just thinks
when people die they live in computers?
Let's move on. "I just feel like I could be
doing more. Wait a minute you guys aren't the real Avengers. Hulk gives it away.
New move I'm working on. Not bad. Oh, god, this feels so strange!
These weapons are crazy dangerous!" Okay, so here we see more of this foiled ATM
robbery, and more of the advanced tech
that these criminals are using. This
weapon looks kind of like the gravity
gun from half-life 2, and we start to see
how this repurposed advanced weaponry is
becoming a problem in this movie. Like,
this guy totally loses control of the laser
as it slices through the entire block,
and we learn that that's what causes
the deli to explode. So the International
trailer actually goes into more of the
background on this. It includes a shot of
Michael Keaton's character, Adrian Toomes,  the vulture, and if you look closely at
the shot, this is in New York's Grand
Central Station, probably shortly after
the Battle of New York in Avengers. Toomes is hacking away at a Chitari
chariot and in the background, you can see a dead Leviathan,. Actually, this is probably
the same Leviathan brought down by Hulk
and Thor in that battle. So, I'm guessing
that this footage is from a flashback
showing how Toomes and his crew
acquired all this tech - they're the guys
who show up to clean up whatever big
Avengers conflict and then gather all
the scraps left behind by Jitari,
Ultron's minions, Hydra controlled
helicarriers, and then they use those
scraps to build new weapons that they
can't really control. So like civil war,
this movie is using the consequences of
past events in the MCU to establish the
conflict of this film, which is a really
economical way to craft a story. Alright,
let's move on. "Listen, Peter. There are people who handle this sort of thing. Can't you
just be a friendly, neighborhood
spider-man? Let go of me, let go of me! Activating parachute."
Okay, so a few really interesting things
here. First there's this shot of Peter as
he watches Stark take off in a jet from
Avengers HQ, and check out this Avengers
logo behind him. Framing the a and circle
behind his shoulder almost makes it look
like a number four, kind of like the
Fantastic Four logo. Now in the past, I
pointed out how this scene kind of feels
like that classic spider-man comic where
spider-man breaks into the Fantastic
Four headquarters in the comics trying
to be part of their team. Like I'm
wondering if Peter is now doing that
with the Avengers. But, this might be an
actual Fantastic Four Easter Egg here.
Marvel Studios head, Kevin Feige, has
admitted that his long-term goal is to
eventually reacquire all Marvel
properties (spider-man, x-men, the
Fantastic Four or sinister six) and
co-producing spider-man with Sony seems
like the first step in this broad Homecoming mission. So maybe, if we're really
lucky, sometime after the infinity war
dust settles, who knows? Peter Parker and
Reed Richards and Bruce Banner could go
on a really nerdy road trip together.
Okay next, the vulture surprises
spider-man by snatching him out of this
neighborhood, and I feel like this might
be the first encounter between these
characters. If you look closely Peter is
clearly chasing this white van and then
it seems like the vulture is pulling him
away from it. So maybe this van contains
more stolen weapons parts, and the
vulture doesn't want spider-man
interfering. But then, if you listen
closely to this part, they did some cool
things with the sound mixing. For one,
that jet engine roar kinda sounds like
the thai fighter from star wars but also, when Toomes looks down at Peter with these menacing
green eyes, this noise that he makes is
actually the sound a real, wild vulture
makes. Listen. So I just love how the sound
guys are using actual, natural effects to
heighten Peter's fear in this moment.
Alright, moving on. "The world's changing,
boys. It's time we change, too. This is my chance to prove myself. But we have a Spanish
quiz. You gotta get better at this part
of the job. I don't understand. I'm intimidating. Oh, hey guys."
Okay, so some big things to point out here: one, I like the joke from Ned that Peter
shouldn't save the world because they
have a Spanish quiz. Again, it seems like
this movie is gonna be really good at
grounding Peter's life as a superhero in
his mundane high school priorities. And
then after more shots of him fighting
Bokeem Woodbine's character in the
school bus yard, we get this quick
exchange with Miles Morales, I mean
Donald Glover, "You gotta get better at
this part of the job." I still have hope
that someday they'll cast Donald Glover as
the Morales version of spider-man, but
this is interesting because it seems
here that Glover is playing a friendly
character to Peter. Like, in the first
teaser Glover seemed to be aligned with
some of the more nefarious characters, so
maybe he like, switches sides to become
more of an ally to Peter, or maybe just
like we saw Toomes do in past trailers,
he's lecturing Peter on how to pick
his battles. Also, I enjoyed this moment of
the glitching eye pieces freaking out
these girls in the tent and Peter looks
especially freaky wrapped up in these
outdoor lights, which he probably crashed
through. They kind of look like those
motion tracking dots that they put on
actors for visual effects mapping, and
yeah, that behind the scenes footage
always looks pretty terrifying. "I kill
wherever I please." Yikes. Let's move on.
"Hey, where are you going? What are you hiding, Peter?
I'm just kidding, I don't care. Bye." So this
section here shows more of this
Washington Monument attack, which I've
actually dissected in past trailer
breakdowns, so go check those out, but I
like how now the action and the music
suddenly ends in this abrupt jump cut to
Michelle, who's Zendaya's character in a
study group, demanding to know where
Peter's running off to. "Hey, where are you going?" In case
you didn't notice, Peter's clothes here
kind of tell us when all this action
takes place. Like check out his "I lost an
electron" t-shirt. It's the same one that
he wears when he meets with Stark in
Avengers HQ, so the reason he's running
off is probably because, you know,
surrogate daddy's calling. Also, this shot
of Peter taking off his tie is
probably him running out of his
homecoming dance, suggesting that that
kiss with Liz Allen that the other
trailers have hinted at probably won't
happen. Or if it does, it won't last long.
There's also a shot from the ferry scene
of this one dude cheering spider-man on,
and notice how the rest of the
passengers are still freaked out and
look at this guy like he's crazy.
Now again, Peter isn't used to this kind
of fan attention, so I think this one
cheer will go to his head, causing him to
think he can take on these ferry arms
dealers on his own, leading to the
vulture showing up and splitting the
ferry in half, and then Iron Man needing to
come in and save Peter's ass, and the asses of all these innocent bystanders. Now the
International trailer shows more of this
sequence, including this awesome shot of
vulture using his wings to snip
spider-man's webbing. So just like the
last trailer when the vulture used his
wings to grab and suspend Peter in the
air, it looks like he can use these
things kind of like how Doc Ock used his
claws in spider-man 2. Also keep in mind
that Peter's webbing is supposed to be
incredibly strong, with an estimated
tensile strength of 120 pounds per
square millimeter of cross section.
That's similar to the strength of a
low-end steel cable, so vulture's wings
being able to cut it here means that
these wing blades must be pretty freakin'
sharp. Okay, let's move on to this final
section. "There's a ton of other sub systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol. I'm sick of Mr.
Stark treating me like a kid! But, you are a kid. Yeah, a kid who can stop a bus with his bare hands."
Okay so here, in case you couldn't tell
what this was, this rubbery texture that
looks like a motherboard is actually the
inside of spider-man's mask, and I love
the detail they designed into it, and the
fact that Peter has to wear this against
his face. Now, Peter and Ned tried to hack
into the mask and they learn that most
of the features have been locked by Stark
under the training wheels protocol. There's
a few things I like about this: one, just
knowing that this suit has all of these
features seems to be setting up Peter
being able to suddenly use all these
awesome abilities at some point later on,
kind of like Chekov's spider-man suit, but
also Peter's whiny reaction here
complaining that Stark treats him like a
kid while Peter's literally jumping up and
down on a bed. This is another example of
how this movie parallels Peter's suit
with something like a video game. It's
like he put in the game and all the best
characters and missions haven't been
unlocked yet. And the trailer ends with
some shots of Peter trying to Sully this
crashing cargo plane over Manhattan. But,
the International trailer actually
gives us more context for what's going
on here. Take a look. "I've got a Plane full of
brand-new Avengers weaponry to load up.
We're gonna put them out of business.
We're going to take everything they got.
You're not gonna stop me."
"So, yeah. Stark is shipping weaponry from
Avengers tower, which Toomes plans to
steal mid-flight, kind of like Bane! And
what exactly is on this plane?
Well if you look closely at this cargo
bay shot, those crates have DODC
written on them, Department of damage
control, a government branch of this
Avengers battle cleanup operation that
Stark is supplying tech to, which Vulture
plans to steal because that would cut
into his private business. Also check out
that Iron Man suit in the background?
That kind of looks like a Mark 42, which
I know, it's been confusing because the
mark 42 and all the other previous marks
got destroyed in Iron Man 3, still, we do
know that Stark just kept building new
Iron Man armor anyway, and he'll have new
armor for infinity war, so maybe this
suit on the plane it's just some
alternate model that he plans to
transport for storage. Either way, I don't
know if vulture would fit in that Iron
Man suit, he's a big guy. Come on, stay out
of this, Bane. So I'm curious what you
guys think about these trailers, and
spider-man homecoming, specifically these
lingering questions that I still have.
One - do you think Peters suit is to iron
Man-y? Like, it's kind of an
interesting debate, right? Like, it's great
that Iron Man and Spider Man are in a
movie together, but is Iron Man's
influence too much? Like, I agree that the
most recent poster was kind of rough.
Like, do you think Iron Man is in this?
But really, I trust director John watts
and Kevin Feige, and I do think that the Stark, tech-y
video game suit will be a key part of
Peter Parker's growth from teen to adult.
And - do you want Marvel to be back in
control of the film rights of all of its
properties? Like, I'm totally with Kevin
Feige when it comes to spider-man and
the Fantastic Four, I think both of those
franchises are long overdue for a
homecoming to Marvel, but like when it
comes to the x-men, I don't know, overall
I've been pretty happy with what Fox has
done with the property. Especially
recently, Deadpool and Logan are like two
of the best superhero movies ever. And I
just don't know if Marvel would have
allowed those movies to be so
stylistically different, and edgy, and
r-rated? Like, sure I was bummed that the
x-men weren't part of the Civil War
movie, I'm just saying that diversity of
storytelling within a genre can be a
good thing. Anyway, let me know what you
think in the comments, and if you like
this video, please hit like and subscribe
to new rockstars, and if you really like
us you can contribute to us on patreon.
Thanks so much to all of our current patrons,
especially Pony Stark. You can hit
mean up on Twitter (@eavoss) with any
thoughts or theories that you have
about spider-man homecoming, or follow
new rock stars on Twitter (@newrockstars) for updates on our videos. Ok,
thanks for watching. Bye.